hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
learning to aggress from complex social
behavior to whole brain light sheet
microscopy
presented by dr sam golden and brought
to you by miltonia biotech
i'm byron hartman and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this is an
interactive event
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation during
the live q a with dr golden
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or you can report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i will now present today's speaker dr
sam golden
assistant professor at the university of
washington department of biological
structure
sam received his phd in neuroscience
from the icann school of medicine
in 2015 under dr scott rousseau
and then he completed post-doctoral
fellowship at the national institute on
drug abuse in 2018
under dr yavin shaham sam joined the
university of washington department of
biological structure in 2019
with a co-appointment as a participating
faculty in the uw center of excellence
in neurobiology of addiction pain and
emotion
dr golden scientific interests encompass
understanding the psychological and
neural mechanisms guiding reward
processing
he's particularly interested in
understanding how neuropsychiatric
disorders
such as maladaptive aggression
depression and substance abuse
subvert basic reward circuitry to
manifest pathological behavior
currently he aims to better define the
intersection of aggression and
motivation
and identify the cellular and circuit
mechanisms that control the transition
from adaptive aggression
to maladaptive aggression seeking
behavior to investigate these mechanisms
the golden lab has pioneered new
applications
of approaches employing chemogenetics
optogenetics calcium imaging
whole mouth light sheets fluorescent
microscopy machine learning and more
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
also check out the links on the right
including a link to the golden lab
website so next we're going to
play sam's pre-recorded presentation and
then we're going to follow that up
with the live q a with dr golden
let's begin
well first i'd like to thank multani and
byron for
inviting me to come give this talk
uh i'll say before we start that this
is the first time i've given a lecture
like this in this format where it's
pre-recorded at home
and then followed by a live question and
answer
and i'm very excited for the question
and answer but i
am a little bit nervous to have to
actually watch myself
prior to that so if you run into any
technical difficulties
uh please bear with me and i promise you
we'll we'll get to the end
um so my name is sam golden i'm an
assistant professor
at the department of biological
structure at the university of
washington
my lab focuses on the study of complex
social behavior
and its intersection with
neuropsychiatric disorders
such as substance abuse and depression
but
our key interest within that larger
field
is looking at this idea of aggression
reward and motivation
and how that interacts with these
neuropsychiatric disorders
so today what i'm going to talk about is
how we model this this idea of
aggression reward
in preclinical rodent models and also
one selective neural population that
we've identified that seems to play a
key role
in regulating aggression reward i'm also
going to
start talking about two other more
preliminary projects
one i'm using machine learning
approaches to analyze social behavior
and the other using whole brain
functional connectomics
to look at uh the pattern of brain
activity that seems to
underlie these states and before i do
that
i'd just like to thank the funding
mechanisms that have allowed us to
answer these questions and even more so
acknowledge the individuals who are
actually doing this work in the lab
so aggression is certainly not something
that has been understudied
going back to the 40s 50s and 60s
there's a really beautiful
and elegant literature using electrical
stimulation
to identify what parts of the brain are
responsible for the initiation of
aggressive behavior
and if you took an intro to psych class
you might remember a video like this one
where we're seeing electrical
stimulation of the lateral hypothalamus
in a cat
leading to a really robust defensive
behavior
and so what these studies identified is
that there's a an
area called the hypothalamic attack area
which
starts in the most lateral portion of
the ventromedial hypothalamus and
extends back into the
lateral hypothalamus proper that really
seems to be key
for initiating this type of aggression
and this work pla
really played a beautiful framework
for more recent studies using
optogenetics or chemogenetic approaches
to
identify the specific neural populations
that are responsible
so this is really seminal work by daeu
lin where she showed that it was
esr-1 alpha positive neurons within this
most lateral aspect the vmh
that when activated induced this really
robust attack behavior
and so when this occurred um it really
when i first saw this video it really
captured
my imagination um because i looked at
this and we've come to sort of
affectionately call the glove test
and what first popped into my mind was
that the animal doesn't really have any
emotional valence
associated with this club and so
optogenetic stimulation of this
population is
turning on or off the behavior but in
the real world we often see that
aggression
is something that has a really high
emotional or motivational state
associated with
whether it's a positive one or a
negative one um and
that question is really at the basis of
the work that i'm going to show
uh in the next in the next 45 minutes or
so
so aggression in mice itself is really
interesting
it's highly stereotyped there are rules
that might seem to understand when it
comes to attacking another mouse
the face is off limits the throat is off
limits the genitals and underbelly are
off limits
and more often than not the strikes or
to the rear flank
of the uh of the intruder mouse but
what's remarkable is that
whether this aggression is due to a
predator
response or due to just attacking a con
specific for other reasons
it often looks really really similar
however
even within a brain region like the vmh
we can see
that the reason for attack can activate
very different neural populations so
here we're using phos which is a marker
of neural activity
i'll be talking about foss a lot
throughout this lecture and so
we use it because it allows us to
identify neurons that were active
during a specific behavioral window in
this case what we can see is that in
response to a predator threat
the more dorsal aspect of the vmh is
engaged well in response to a
attack on a con specific it appears to
be the more lateral
and so this right away tells us that
there must be dissociable neck
mechanisms guiding different forms of
aggressive behavior
um and this has certainly been shown in
humans and this is an example from james
maron that i really like
it is a study done in healthy uh
college volunteers where they were asked
to listen to either repetitive or
reactive auditory scripts
of aggression or a control condition and
what they found
is that there are really different
patterns of cortical activity
associated with these different types of
auditory scripts that
are asking these individuals to imagine
themselves in an aggressive situation
this type of differential pattern is
even more
obvious or more identifiable when we
move into
the pathological forms of human
aggression so for example
repeat violent offenders uh have been
shown to have both functional and
structural
abnormalities in limbic brain regions
associated with
their repeat violent offenses and so
the way that i try to conceptualize
this study looking at aggression reward
or aggression motivation
is to do it within the framework of
other really well validated approaches
i think one of the great examples of
this has been the approach taken by
the nationalist on drug abuse which uses
this idea of looking at drug use
followed by some form of abstinence and
relapse
and i'd like to point out that even for
all of the pre-clinical work that has
been done
using these models there still hasn't
been
much of an improvement in relapse rates
over the decades to numerous drugs of
abuse
and i'm going to come back to why i
think that's important in a second
so we want to take this idea and see if
we could use similar preclinical models
uh to look at this idea of pathological
aggression so
being involved in aggressive encounters
going through some form of abstinence
from that aggression and then seeing if
there is a relapse liability
just as one example with many caveats
but i think really highlights why this
is interesting is if we look at
recidivism rates for repeat violent
offenders within the united states we
can see that almost 75 percent
of violent offenders are back in jail
within five years for repeat violent
crimes
and of course this is one extreme
example that has many many caveats to
its interpretation
but i think it's much much easier for us
to just look at
how enthusiastically followed sports
like mixed martial arts and football are
to see that there are definitely this
idea of
reward and motivation involved with
these aggressive encounters
across all different spectrums of human
behavior
and so the question is can we reverse
translate that can we go from this idea
that we see all the time in humans
and move it into a preclinical model so
we can begin to identify
the neural substrates and mechanisms
that are guiding it
um so luckily there there are some
really great
pre-clinical approaches to looking at
stress-related behaviors and i think one
really classic one
is resident intruder testing or chronic
social to feed stress so in chronic
social to feed stress we take a
larger more aggressive cd1 this is an
outbred mouse
it is generally older and sexually
experienced relative to the
smaller subordinates inbred c57 intruder
this is a rigged game because of the
size age and sexual experience
difference between
these two mice the cd1 almost always
chooses to engage in and win any
aggressive encounters against the c-57
and classically we use this approach not
to look at the cd1
but rather look at stress susceptibility
or resilience
in the c-57 and so this is what i did
originally in graduate school i spent
many
many many many hours looking at videos
of these my speeding up these mice but
to look at depression-related behaviors
but what i was anecdotally always much
more interested in
was the fact that we seem to get a
really even split of cd1s that were
aggressive enough
to be used as tools during chronic
social defeat stress
and so in my mind when uh they used
beautiful paper came out in 2011
and i was staring at these these mice
fighting for for far too many hours
uh i really wanted to understand why
that individual variability existed why
some were aggressive and some were not
so we went ahead and screened a cohort
of several hundred
outbred cd1s for aggression over three
days of resident intruder testing what
we found is about
70 percent of any given cohort of cd1s
exhibited some level of aggression
across three days
but what was really interesting is that
if you look at the mean latency
over the three days between each of
those aggressive mice there's a really
beautiful spectrum
and so now this allows us to look at the
animals that have very low latency or
very high levels of aggression uh medium
level
or relatively weak aggression and of
course animals that fail to show any
aggression at all
so using this type of individual
variability we can start to ask what's
different
why are some extremely aggressive why
are some not aggressive at all
unfortunately with resident intruder
testing
you can't really differentiate between
reactive aggression and repetitive
aggression
or that is you know regression that's in
response to a threat that fight or
flight
response or aggression that's because an
animal finds it rewarding
because it's a forced encounter in their
home cage so
to get around that we needed to develop
a new method
that would allow us to isolate the
initiation of aggression
from the expression of reward and to do
that we used aggression
aggression condition place preference so
an aggression cpp
you have a three chamber apparatus a
chamber on the left a chamber in the
middle and a chamber on the right
and the middle chamber is neutral but
the left and right chambers have
significantly different contextual cues
so for example the size of the floor
grids
might be used the coloration of the
walls
the light gradient oftentimes labs will
use an olfactory cue that's different
between the two contexts
but the point here is that it's very
easy for
a a mouse to identify context a
and context b and so uh using this
type of apparatus we could pair one side
with a fight or an aggressive
interaction and the other side
with the absence of a fight or other
appropriate control condition
and so we pre-screened aggressors or
cd1s
to find out they're aggressive or
non-aggressive and then put them through
the cpp procedure
where they're contained to either
context a
or context b and they can't get to the
other side
for several pairings and then on the
test day we give them
full access to the whole three chambers
without an intruder present
and so that the cd1 can run around and
it can choose which side it wants to
spend more time on
and if it chooses to spend more time on
the fight paired side
we'd call that an aggression condition
place preference whereas if it wants to
spend more time on the
unpaired side we'd call that a condition
place aversion what we found was that
the pre-screened aggressors form a cpp
while the nine non-aggressors form a cpa
so this is really exciting because this
allows us now to begin to
start looking at the neural mechanisms
that are guiding not the initiation
but the motivation we went on to do some
other experiments to really better
define
this phenomenon of regression cpp and so
i want to highlight
three main findings the first is that
this is a very plastic behavior so
what we did is we took a large cohort of
cd1s and put them through not
three days of pre-screening to identify
if they're aggressive or non-aggressive
but 10 days and what we found is that
over the course of these 10 screening
sessions
starting with animals that were not
aggressive or aggressive
roughly 50 percent of the non-aggressive
mice
stochastically switched to an aggressive
phenotype
more importantly once they switched here
these animals that switched are
indicated in gray
they went on to form a conditioned place
preference
to the fight paired sides these were
mice that were previously non-aggressive
became aggressive and then went on to
actually form a condition place
preference for the fight-paired chamber
uh so there's a behavioral plasticity
here it can be
learned and it's also quite persistent
if we test the same animals
for cpp several weeks later we find that
the aggressors still prefer
the aggression paired context and the
non-aggressors still
prepare sorry prefer uh the
uh intruder unpaired context
and again those that switched look like
your standard aggressors
so there are some limitations to using
cpp a major limitation is that we still
can't appropriately differentiate
between
reactive and repetitive aggression
because again it's still a forced
encounter we're still forcing the cd1
into context a or forcing them into
context b
and so luckily there has been a solution
already identified in the literature
which is awkward aggression or training
a mouse to lever press for access to a
subordinate intruder
and this is some really beautiful work
that was initially done
by the mitchek lab in the early 2000s
where they showed that
output mouse will actually nose poke for
access to a subordinate intruder
and so we wanted to do is take this
operant approach and make it higher
throughput
and then apply some of the gold
standards from the addiction literature
but within the context of aggression
reward seeking
so there are certainly some core
features that are
commonly held to indicate an addiction
like rodent
these are for drugs these are persistent
relapses during abstinence
a very high level of motivation to seek
out or amount of effort they'll expend
to seek out the drugs
and continuing to work for the drugs
even in the face of severe adverse
consequences
so the question was if we took our
aggressive animals our aggressive cd1s
and applied these same metrics using
operant procedures
would we be able to identify any mice
any aggressive mice that meet or exceed
the commonly held criteria
for addiction-like behavior and so this
is how we actually do this
we have operant chambers just like upper
chambers you'd use for for drugs of
abuse
in our case though we have two active
levers one on the left side here
one on the right side here the active
lever on the left
is paired with something with whatever
we like in this case it's a highly
palatable food reinforcer
but it could be alcohol it could be
other drugs of abuse
the lever on the right is paired with an
automatic guillotine door
that allows access to a subordinate
intruder
to make this high throughput and
amenable to the
types of neuroscience techniques that
we're commonly using we have a
multi-mouse magazine for the c57
intruder
so there's actually a mouse on the
bottom and a mouse on the top and when
the automatic door opens we can
push in the intruder and then we can
cycle them rapidly so that one
individual can run a bunch of boxes
at one time and here's what it actually
looks like so in this case what we're
looking at
is a variation on self-administration
where there are two active levers in the
box the first active lever
needs to be pushed 10 times once it's
pushed 10 times the second active lever
becomes available
which only needs to be pressed once
which leads to the opening of the
automatic guillotine door
and the and access to the subordinate
intruder
the cd1 does all of this voluntarily in
this case they have to work quite hard
to do it they need to go through a chain
of events to gain access
and then they also get to choose what
they want to do when the intruder is
present
so in this case after about 10 seconds
the cd1 chose to attack
so using this approach we can now look
at a completely
voluntary form of aggression motivation
when we do this over several days we see
that they learn to self-administer
quite well we keep track of two metrics
was it a
reinforced or rewarded trial so did they
press the lever that gained access
and also once they had access to the
intruder did they choose to engage in an
aggressive interaction
we separate the mice as soon as the
first aggressive bout is done to make
sure that none of them are harmed
and this also allows us to get between
12 and 20 trials
during each day's training and so in
this case what we can see is that they
acquire the
lever pressing for aggression and that
they attack on the majority
of trials when they do lever press so
this was very exciting because it
gave us a high throughput very
operationalized procedure to look at
operant aggression self-administration
um but then again we wanted to come back
to this idea
of relapse liability and so we started
with forced abstinence which is very
simple it's where you
move the animal out of the environment
out of the operand chambers and then
re-expose them under extinction
conditions at some later time point
and here we chose either one day or 15
days after the end of training and what
we saw
was a strong time independent relapse to
aggression seeking behavior
of course this is not one of the gold
standards that i just presented but it
was very exciting
for us because it suggested that we
should be moving in this direction
and so we then went ahead and actually
did apply all of these other
drugs all these other core uh or
cardinal
approaches for identifying
addiction-like
so we took for example a very large
cohort we put them through
self-administration
early and late relapse something we call
voluntary abstinence so involuntary
abstinence
we take advantage of the fact that we
have two active levers within each
operand chamber and we chain they train
the aggressive mice
to self-administer highly palatable food
under non-food restricted conditions
and also to self-administer aggression
and then we give them a choice we give
them a series of choice trials where we
can say which would you prefer
would you prefer access to highly
palatable food or would you prefer
access to a subordinate intruder and
what we find under these choice
parameters
is that the vast majority of aggressive
mice will choose food
over fighting this type of voluntary
abstinence
is how we can model something like
contingency management
from the clinic so under continuing to
contingency management
a human who is coming in will be
provided a voucher
uh maybe for money maybe for a job in
exchange for
providing clean urine and this type of
approach is highly effective
at attenuating drug seeking in humans
and this is how we can actually try to
use a similar approach in preclinical
rodent models
we also put them through progressive
ratio so progressive ratio
is a procedure where each subsequent
reinforcer
requires a higher level of effort than
the previous
and it's not an exact exponential but
it's essentially like 2
4 8 16 32 and at some point
the mouse will say this is just far too
much effort
to expend to get this reinforcer and so
it gives us what we call a break point
or
the point at which they will no longer
continue working
for that reward and we also used
punishment
so under punishment conditions 50 of all
reinforced
lever presses are paired with a foot
shock and so you can imagine that as
this
contingent foot shock occurs the mice
learn very rapidly
to no longer level press for the reward
in this case aggression
and so we put this large cohort of cd1s
through all of these procedures
so that we could look for any
subpopulations that might develop
what we found using uh cluster analysis
is that we get this unsupervised cluster
analysis is that we find two different
populations of
aggressive animals one we term typical
aggression seeking and another we turn
compulsive aggressive seeking so the
compulsive aggressive seeking population
is roughly 20 percent of any given
cohort
and if we reanalyze all those individual
data points now by these new groups what
we find is that the compulsive
aggressive seeking animals
are just off the charts by any of the
metrics that we use
whether it's attacks relapse choice so
again most mice will choose
food over fighting these guys will
choose fighting over food
break point to put this in perspective a
break point of 20 reinforcers is roughly
600 level presses
just for that most recent reinforcer so
they're working incredibly hard
for access to fight and they're
completely punishment and sensitive
so this is really really interesting
because now we have an opportunity
where we can look at totally voluntary
aggression self-im
self-administration uh along with all of
these forms of relapse forced relapse
voluntary uh absence
or punishment induced absence but also
we can identify
subpopulations that meet the criteria
for compulsive
aggressive behavior so we can look at
the typical mice
the compulsive aggressive mice uh all
under these completely voluntary
conditions um and so using these types
of approaches
uh this slide really summarizes what we
know
about the neural mechanisms of
repetitive aggression
one story that i'd really like to
highlight now has recently been
published
is looking at the role of the nucleus
accumbens so the nucleus of cummins is a
critical
brain region within the reward circuit
it's
maybe thought of as the interface
between motivation
action it's composed predominantly
of what are called medium spiny neurons
and they come in two flavors
d1 receptor expression or dopamine one
receptor expressing or d2
expressing neurons they make up about 95
percent uh there's also interneurons
if you think of back again to maybe that
intro to psych
of course the d1 population is often
called the direct
pathway in the d2 indirect pathway
so what's really uh
interesting about this about this is
it's been critical
or identified as a critical brain region
in other types of natural and
non-natural reward as well such as drugs
of abuse
and so we wanted to identify if it was
also involved in aggression
self-administration and relapse and so
again we used foss that marker of neural
activity
to look in the nucleus accumbens and
identify if it was active during either
reinforced
aggression or relapse compared to
control groups and what we found is that
under both reinforced conditions and
aggression seeking conditions
we have a strong recruitment of the
nucleus accumbens
shell like i said it's made up
predominantly of two different cell
types the d1 and d2 expressing so our
next question was
one uh could we recapitulate that
general
activity which we were able to do but
also is there a specific population
within the accumbens the d1 or the d2
that are really engaged by this behavior
what we found was that
both the d1 and the d2
msns were equally boss positive during
either reinforced aggression or relapse
to aggression seeking so this wasn't
what we were anticipating
but it was very very exciting
unfortunately to causally
identify the role that d1 and d2 neurons
are are playing we need to have access
to genetic tools
and as i mentioned we tend to use these
outbred these larger more aggressive
outbred mice these cd1s and outbred mice
are not available with these with these
cree tools so what we had to do is come
up with a strategy that would allow us
to isolate the genetic populations of
interest
we did this through a transgenic hybrid
breeding strategy where we can take our
d1 or d2
cree inbred mouse cross it with our
outbred cd1
and take the outbred uh f1 hybrid
population that now contains
the d1 or d2 cree transgene that we need
to use to
isolate these populations this actually
you know gets us a completely novel new
new cross and so we need to go through
and developmentally and biochemically
validate these crosses and make sure
that they still show the behavior that
we want
and don't have any off-target molecular
effects as well
what's very interesting is these
transgenic hybrids are about the same
size
uh over the course of development as the
cd1 and much larger
than the c57 parent and i'm not showing
it here but they also show very high
levels of aggression whether it's
reactive aggression and resident
intruder
or operant aggression in
self-administration
and so what we could then do now with
these f1 hybrids that have cree in
either the d1 or d2 population with the
nucleus accumbens
is use chemogenetic approaches to
artificially inactivate
these populations during uh either
self-administration or relapse behaviors
again we targeted the nucleus accumbens
shell because that's where we identified
the largest population of foss
reactivity
and when we do this what we found was
even though both the d1 and d2
populations were false positive
only the d1 population seems to be
playing
a critical role in controlling both
reinforced aggression
as well as relapse to aggression seeking
behavior
so now we can say with some confidence
that there are cell type specific
differences
in repetitive aggression seeking
so i just want to now give you an
example a better
example of what this aggression can look
like
so i mentioned that we keep track of two
metrics
was it a rewarded trial so did they
press the lever
and was it an attack so did they attack
binary yes or no
but if you look at this video you can
see that there's really a lot more going
on
there are tail rattles lateral threat
displays
all different types of attacks the
intruder can be exhibiting different
types
of active or passive coping behaviors
in response to these aggressions and we
don't
get any of that in these experiments and
the reason we don't is if i ask someone
in the audience to volunteer
to manually score frame by frame
hundreds of hours of these videos
i i don't think i'm going to get a lot
of volunteers
it's incredibly time demanding uh it's
prone to observer drift in observer bias
and it's one of the main reasons that
complex social behavior
is not often incorporated into many of
the pre-clinical models that we use to
look at neuropsychiatric disease
and so we wanted to see if we could
maybe overcome that with
some of the tools that have recently
become available
so in this example uh all of the
behavioral annotations that you're
seeing read out on the left side
are automated and that is this video has
never been scored
by a human and we can do this using
machine learning based
approaches obviously this
is something that i think many graduate
students and undergraduate students
you can you can hear their sigh of
relief seeing a video like this because
this is a really again a tremendously
subjective and time-consuming process to
do manually
so we wanted to take advantage of recent
advances in pose estimation
um which are basically uh again machine
learning approaches
um to identify specific features in a
video
and apply them with
predictive classifiers of these complex
social behaviors and to do this
we came up with a software that we've
called simba i'll talk about it in a
little detail in the in the upcoming
slides
and this is the team that has really
poured their heart into developing this
open source pipeline
but what simba allows us to do is make
these types of predictive
complex social behavior predictive
classifiers without any specialized
hardware
we also wanted to be very clear that we
could have transparency and
explainability of the models we're
working with
again many behavioral neuroscientists do
not come myself included
with classical training in computer
science and
uh many of the machine learning tools
that exist sort of operate within a
black box
and that makes it really challenging to
troubleshoot them or trust
them and so what we wanted to be able to
do is was
bring transparency and explainability to
this process
as well as have checkpoints for human
validation so we could make sure
everything was going well
and correct it when it's not and again
not require
programming or computer science
experience and so it's very simple it's
just this very simple process
okay it's really not that simple what
simba basically allows us to do is
walk a walk a behavioral neuroscientist
or any other user
through the process of processing videos
generating or
importing a pose estimation behavioral
tracking model
building classifiers of these behaviors
for us it might be attack for someone
else it might be grooming
and then lastly actually analyze those
and create
visualizations i just want to point out
symbol is 100
open source simva stands for simple
behavioral analysis
uh so all of the files that were used um
all the code that was generated as well
as all of the videos
or files that were used to create either
the tracking or predictive classifiers
are openly available
and you can you know feel free to
screenshot this and go check it out
and so coming back i'm just going to
sort of slowly walk us through each of
these just at a superficial level
uh this is all published as a pre-print
so if you're interested in any one
component you can go ahead and pull the
pre-print and get the details
so the first step is obviously
pre-processing video it seems like a
pretty straightforward thing but when
you have hundreds of videos
acquired over the course of experiment
it can actually be quite daunting
so what we've done is we've gone through
and provided a pipeline that allows for
either
processing a single video or a whole
batch of videos with cropping
trimming changing colors enhancing
various filters things of that nature
but basically getting everything
processed to the point
where it's now possible to move forward
with analysis
the second component is is actually
importing the tracking model so these
pose
estimation architectures that i'm
talking about are things like deep lab
cut which is very popular
depose kit sleep each of these use
neural networks to identify identify
various features on the mouse such as
the nose the ears
the tails the flanks whatever you like
and then we can take those identified
features their x y coordinates
and use them to create the predictive
classifiers
so one of the things that we thought
would be really critical to get
adoption of this type of machine
learning approach into the behavioral
neuroscience labs is making it
really flexible so as you can see
we tend to use a lot of annotations we
like to have the nose the ears the
flanks the the tail the tail base
on both mice but for other people they
might only need four of these body ports
and so what simba allows us to do is
flexibly utilize any of these
feature or something any of these pose
estimation
annotation schemes and then use them in
the next steps
more recently deep lab cut has released
a multi-animal module
and leap has released their social leap
module that allows us now
to work with similar looking mice and so
we've actually updated in the most
recent release of a few weeks ago of
simba
the ability to use these types of pose
estimation schemes as well
right now we fully support two mice but
we're slowly rolling in this n plus one
where we have up to five mice
so once you have your pose estimation
that's when you really are now you've
gone through the basic
process of prepping your videos getting
your tracking and
now you're really into the heart of
simba which is generating predictive
classifiers and so we have project
management
that allows us to calibrate your videos
for distance and time
that allows us to correct outliers
extract features
and of course go through all of the
validation and optimization
and explainability steps that i uh
insinuated earlier
so what does that actually look like so
again this is all gui driven
so that it doesn't require any
programming experience but first we
remove
any pose estimation that was inaccurate
or is impossible between the multiple
animals
we are also then annotating any regions
or
objects within an environment that will
be really critical or crucial for
incorporating as features
within our machine learning pipeline i
also just point out that
even though it wasn't our intention it's
become very popular to use simba
not for machine learning purposes but
just for getting really thorough
descriptive statistics
of pose estimation and certainly that is
possible
using the simba pipeline as well
so once you have your your pose
estimation you've
corrected any outliers you've added any
regions of interest you actually need to
go through and
identify the behaviors that you want to
be able to automate the classification
of
so that's what you're seeing here in
this video is just an example of
walking through the gui you can select a
video the video pops up
you can then annotate the specific
behaviors that are present on any given
frame
and use those to develop the
relationships between the pose
estimation features that encapsulate
the behavior that you want to find and
so this is what it actually looks like
on the back end
as the animals are interacting since
you've behaviorally annotated the frames
of interest whether it's aggression or
grooming
or lateral threat display we are then
identifying the relationship between
those pose estimations
and all these possible combinations of
other relationships the reason we want
to do this is then to be able to say
in a new video with high accuracy
and high precision that these behaviors
are present or not
and we can do that at levels that are
above
your typical undergraduate but certainly
at or above a well-trained scorer
so when i come back to this last bit on
the ability to evaluate these
classifiers this is i think really a
critical component because
without the ability to make sure they're
working as intended and easily correct
them when they're not
it becomes a very harrowing and
challenging job
to create really well validated
classifiers and so
we built this into simba so that you can
automatically generate
not just the ones i'm going to show you
but many many different types of
evaluations
precision recall is one that's very
popular because it tells us
what is the optical the optimal
discrimination threshold
so there's always a range of
probabilities that an event has occurred
and you need to set a threshold when it
is a binary yes or no
what's the optimal threshold to use do i
need to add more training data to the
training data set to be able to get
these classifiers you can identify that
with learning curves we also use
genie importances and permutation
importance to understand
how important or predictive any given
feature
is within these classifiers and so all
of this is generated and made available
so that we can go in
and understand what's occurring and of
course you can get the actual
prediction trees that were utilized as
well
so the final step is going in and
actually analyzing the data
there's many many tools that we have
available here but i think the ones that
people like to see are the
visualizations and so you can go in
generate overlays pick the parts of the
data frame that you want to go along
with that and
incorporate it into your analysis so now
what we can do
is we can come back to examples like
this where we previously only had
rewards and lever presses and now go
back and ask during d1
inhibition how are these behaviors
actually shifting and get a much deeper
dive
we're also in the process of aligning
these types of
automated approaches with
fibrophotometry and calcium imaging
and i think more exciting to myself
is moving forward with unsupervised
analysis of the previously identified
supervised epochs
so as an example here
what we call attack or what we believe
in an attack
could actually here indicated in red be
made up of several
different motifs and so now we can go in
using unsupervised analyses
from simba and begin to tease apart the
individual components
of these more complex behaviors as well
and so all of that
is ongoing work so the idea there is to
bring
behavioral neuroscience into this big
data field
which is my hope
we're going to be able to pair with some
of the functional connectomics that i'm
about to speak to you on
so whole brain functional economics
gives us the opportunity
to now ask not just what brain reasons
we have already identified and what the
role is in aggression related behaviors
but also look at all the non-canonical
regions that have yet to be identified
we do this through brain clearing and
then imaging with light sheet
fluorescent light sheet fluorescent
microscopy this is
uh the work of postdoc in my lab eric in
collaboration with tyrone
at nida they've really been been the
heart behind this project
but what we can do is basically take a
brain make it transparent
and then image it as an intact volume
without having to cut it up
so what that allows us to do as an
example or get these really
high level really nice
renders 3d 3d accurate renders
of whole intact brains here i'm
obviously just showing in this example
a thin 300 micron slice of a whole
intact brain
in red is foss again that marker of
neural activity
uh in this case in green is thigh one
gfp which is just a marker of
glutamatergic neurons
and we can go through generate these
volumetric data sets
and then identify the brain regions that
are most
active in these intact brains during our
behaviors
this is what it actually looks like when
we're looking at a brain analytically
each one of these is a false positive
neuron
and uh i'm not going to get into it now
how we go about the registration and
segmentation
uh of these data sets uh but once they
are registered and segmented we can go
in
and start really figuring out the the
the ensembles
or patterns of brain regions that are
active here i just want to show you what
it actually looks like
um so on the top is a no test control on
the bottom
is a relapse to aggression seeking brain
and
even by eye you can see that there are
there's certainly enriched
patterns of foss in the day 15 relapse
so what we're in the process of doing
now is going back
finding all of these false positive
neurons and then performing the analysis
that allows us to understand which of
these ensembles
are engaged by reinforced aggression
by relapse to aggression seeking and
also by other behaviors
so before closing here there is one
new preliminary data set i'd really like
to share
which is not on aggression but which
i think is very exciting which is
looking at the whole brain
functional connectome of incubation of
craving
so incubation of craving is is a
phenomenon that was first identified by
jeff grimm and naveen shaham in the
early 2000s which is that
the longer an animal is abstained from a
drug of abuse
when they're reintroduced to the context
where that
drug is available they will work harder
for it so this is called
incubation of craving because the longer
the animal is abstained
the more they crave that drug this was
first shown with cocaine but it's also
more recently
been extended to other classes of drugs
and has also been shown in rats for
sucrose
what we've been working on recently is
is looking at highly palatable
food self-administration and incubation
at day one day 15 or day
60.
what we've observed is that behaviorally
we do recapitulate this incubation of
craving phenomenon for highly palatable
food at later time points
so now the question is what areas of the
brain
are engaged by this incubation
phenomenon
so here i'm just going to show a video
which summarizes
uh some of the differences and patterns
of phos immunoreactivity that we observe
on the top left are home cage controls
uh and then on the top right our day one
relapse bottom left day 15
and bottom right day 60. and what you
can see just by eye
is that at the later relapse points
there's a
strong enrichment of foss relative to
earlier abstinence so
here i'm showing that data summarized
on the left is just going in the
pattern of most foss to least foss
across all experimental groups
and on the right the home cage control
we can see that there are distinct
uh differences or patterns of false
enrichment
if we reorganize those by experimental
groups
what we begin to see is that during
incubation
there's a strong enrichment not
necessarily of unique brain regions or
not really onlining of unique brain
regions
but rather a sensitization of brain
regions that have
slowly been ramping up during that time
during that abstinence period
and of course we do see some significant
regions even after
correction for multiple comparison many
of them within the
cortex and the hippocampus and so right
now this is very preliminary we've only
completed collecting this data you know
several weeks ago and we're still
crunching through it
but we think this is really exciting
because it's an example of an
application for whole brain imaging
where we now have a very clear answer to
a question that's existed since the
behavior was first discovered
does incubation involve the recruitment
of new brain regions at later time
points
or the sensitive sensitization of
similar brain regions across time and i
think now
that at least our preliminary data
strongly suggests the sensitization
of brain regions across time rather than
a recruitment
of novel ones and so to give you an idea
here is this uh
ensemble of brain regions that we've
identified
and so now the goal of course is to take
this approach like we've just shown you
here for incubation
but apply it to reinforced aggression
relapse to aggression seeking behavior
in combination with this machine
learning
approach to behavior so we have big
behavior
big imaging and we'd like to pair them
to really try to understand
how these various brain regions are
relating to the more complex components
of these behaviors so with that i'm just
going to say that simba
is available currently and anyone who
would like to go and give it a try
please please do and i'd also like to
point out that although i didn't speak
about it we also have
ongoing projects looking at the
intersection of ptsd
and maladaptive aggression and opioid
withdrawal and
escalated aggression with that i'd just
like to once again thank the members of
my
lab that have really of our lab that
have really made all of this work
possible and i think we will now
transition to the live portion of the
question and answer
thank you professor golden for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of the questions
that we have time for
okay so the first question in um
in bipolar disorder the patient will
have an altered mood swing
uh what will be the brain activity uh
and
aggressiveness maximum limit in these
patients can you comment on this
question dr golden
uh i can try so
obviously all the work that we do is in
pre-clinical models uh is the sound
coming through okay i
just want to make sure i think so
yes i can hear you quite well right if
you can hear me then i think we're
we're good uh yeah so we can't really
comment too much on
on what's happening in a clinical sense
here
um what i can say is that
there is a clear need to understand the
intersection
between maladaptive social behavior like
aggression
and which is clinically often
represented more as irritability or
agitation
uh in these contexts uh and how those do
connect with this basic neurocircuitry
that guides
aggression itself in the intersection of
motivation
we have not really explored that yet
in our preclinical models we certainly
don't have a model of bipolar disorder
some that we are working on which i
think are related are
i i mentioned in our closing slides
there are projects looking at
the intersection of ptsd uh and either
escalated
or attenuated maladaptive aggressive
behavior uh
and we're just it's too soon to to
really get into
any preliminary data uh that we've
identified on those in terms of the
the neuroanatomy uh so i can't really
speak to that yet but it's something
that's definitely on our radar and those
are the types of questions
the the translatable questions that we
want to begin to address
um with these approaches but it's it's
early days
and we're still you know very much in
process on this
thank you dr goldman uh next question
is there any predictive value at the
beginning of your training
with the three chamber tests so if you
would do the three chamber tests
at the start of the training of the cd1
could you predict which ones will become
aggressive
even if they're not aggressive at the
initial you know initial start of the
test that is a really good question
uh and it's it's one that we are
actively looking into now so
nostalgia goodwin uh her ongoing project
right now one of them our main one
um is a very ambitious uh attempted
tackling bat what are the
similarities and differences between
reactive and repetitive aggression
neural circuitry
and so what we can tell you anecdotally
uh so far
is we always pre-screen our cd1s at the
beginning and either
some type of resident intruder task or
simple magazine training where we
introduce them to the operant
environment and
do some pavlovian conditioning to the
queue and the presentation of an
intruder
and the aggressive mice tend to go on to
to lever press very nicely for
repetitive aggression
what's interesting is at least
anecdotally is it's not terribly
predictive of the ones that show a
non-aggressive phenotype under those
reactive conditions so what i mean is
even animals that might pre-screen as
relatively non-aggressive in a resident
intruder
can still go on to become very good
uh lever pressers for repetitive
aggression and
uh i think that ties in somewhat to the
data we showed with our aggression cpp
of there being a really nice behavioral
flexibility or plasticity
once animals start to win and continue
to have access to winning interactions
so what can i say so to answer your
question a little more specifically if
an animal
is aggressive reactively they tend to
acquire repetitive aggression
well if they are non-aggressive under
reactive conditions it is not
anecdotally highly predictive of how
they'll perform under
repetitive tasks but i think that's a
super i mean
that's a super interesting observation
and it's one we're really following up
on now
i know hopefully we'll have some some
more answers in a year or two
excellent thank you the next question
hi dr golden thank you so much for your
presentation this is a bit of a specific
method question
in your aggression cpp paper it says 10
minutes in each context
uh intruder paired versus unpaired
in the entry repaired context did you
ever consider five minutes alone
first so that the mice developed
stronger territorially
uh to that side before the introduction
of the intruder
that's a it's a good technical question
on how to design
and execute a cpp or other type of
social context task
so we did not do that that was not one
of the permutations on
the procedure that we played around with
them you know
housing them overnight the night before
for example
on the aggression paired side or
anything of that nature i have no doubt
that that could absolutely
influence um how
how the animals will behave and so i
think it's worth considering you're
certainly being aware of
in designing these types of procedures
but we never specifically addressed that
territoriality especially in mice is
obviously a key
driver of reactive aggression we haven't
at least in our lab looked much more in
more detail into how territoriality
interacts with aggression reward
but it's you know it's a very
interesting question to think about
thank you sam next
thanks for the great talk dr golden i
have two questions
one from a social defeat standpoint how
do you think the individual variation in
cd1 aggression
affects the ultimate vulnerability or
resiliency
of the intruder mice is the variability
in cd1 aggression
one of the reasons for the split aka can
you
shift intruder mice to resilient or
susceptible
based on latency and the amount of
aggression
but that's the first question i'll let
you answer that one first before we post
a second
yeah so that's yeah so
i mentioned that a lot of our
conceptualization
of how we've been looking at aggression
really derives from the much larger
and much more fleshed out chronic social
defeat stress
literature um and so this is sort of a
segway not really relevant to the to the
data i showed but it's a really good
question
um you know over 10 days of chronic
social defeat stress when you're using
uh 10 different aggressors that are
getting rotated each day with each of
the intruders so they're not seeing
you're not having the same pairings on
each subsequent day there's going to be
variability
in the levels of aggression that any
given intruder
is uh exposed to and
there's no doubt that that type of
variability can can
influence ultimately susceptibility and
resilience
there's no way around that you know it
takes two to tango and we can't control
the level of aggression that a cd1 shows
during a social defeat procedure
we can certainly remove cd1s that are
not showing aggression
and that's done very regularly in these
procedures
but it gets to a much more interesting
point which is what are the intruders
doing in response to the aggression
that's being delivered
are they using active or passive coping
behavioral
coping strategies uh so in the c-57 you
know they could be
going going like this it's my
interpretation of them
showing a subordination or they could be
turning tail and fleeing
under more active conditions and i think
that is really
the future of understanding the
molecular mechanism and circuit-based
mechanisms that we're finding
we can't control how much aggression
they get we can certainly
begin to categorize in much greater
detail using simva
using java using unsupervised approaches
there are so many that are coming out
now that you know need to be evaluated
and incorporated into these types of
behavioral procedures
we can use those now to separate in
animals that use active versus passive
and animals that got
high levels of aggression versus
moderate levels of aggression over the
10 days
the differences that we're seeing and i
have no doubt that we will begin to
better be able to predict under those
types of analyses
animals that ultimately go on to show
susceptible phenotypes
or resilient phenotypes because this is
a behavior and
and there there's a cause and
consequence at plan which we just
haven't had
i mean i certainly have not had the
ability to
to to really break down in a very
granular way
i think the tools are now available and
easy enough to incorporate in
really normal not computer sciencey
behavioral neuroscience labs to start
addressing those exact questions
and so i think i answer that i think i'm
a very long-winded answer
yes i think the cd1 plays a very
important role
in the behavior of the c-57 excellent
and the follow-up question from the same
viewer was from your
simba behavioral analysis system can we
add our own behaviors on top of the tail
rattle
for example to predict our own features
during an aggression session
yeah so i guess i didn't make that that
clear enough and so you know there's a
very good question
simba is agnostic to the behavior that
you want to identify it's supervised
machine learning you might you you're
supervising it
to identify the behaviors that you want
we've released
in what's already available a set
of what we think are core behaviors for
resident intruder and chronic social
dispute stress
i'm both the part of the resident and
the part of the intruder
so aloe grooming under different
you know vigorous versus less vigorous
conditions attack
uh if your tracking is very good if your
pose estimation is very good
things like tail rattle we also include
lateral threat display
fleeing pursuit all of these but that's
just the ones that you know we have a
personal interest in the lab and
obviously those are going to be very
different
across labs and so what simba allows is
the ability to go in and generate your
own classifiers for your own behaviors
of interest
and if you already have annotated videos
like with j watcher or boris
or uh you know if you you know if you
like
know this but uh the easel vision
observer you can take those
already annotated data sets and feed
them
into simba and not have to go through
and re-behaviorally annotate your videos
we've also incorporated a bunch of tips
and tricks
such as pseudo-labeling that allow you
to much more rapidly identify the
behaviors of interest that you're
looking for
than if you're just sitting there with a
stopwatch in an excel sheet and so we're
really trying to make that
painless now the reason though
that we really think this is important
isn't just as a tool
to in your own lab or in your own
experiments identify specific behaviors
what we really want to be able to do is
create a very common language
of what i call attack and what you call
attack
so that uh when we look at the molecular
or circuit mechanisms that we're trying
to associate
or are trying to say play a causal role
in these behaviors we're
actually talking about the same behavior
it's
that's obviously something that is not
occurring right now in behavioral
neuroscience
uh and oftentimes even the the
ethological breakdown of what someone is
calling behavior is even
presented in the methods and so our hope
is that by using these types of
automated approaches where i can give
you
my attack clapper buyer you can give me
your tail rattle classifier or whatever
not only will we then be using the exact
same behavioral language
for the comparisons we're making at a
higher level
but as we build on them or as they
change there are metrics we can use to
very clearly identify
not just observationally but
mathematically why they're different or
similar
and so i didn't get into that because i
think that's a much more advanced use of
simba
but it's certainly something we're
really excited and really digging into
on our end and trying to incorporate
into the gui so that it's easily
accessible to everyone
um as we as we try to make new
classifiers disseminate them
and share them among the apps
thanks a lot sam so um i'm going through
the questions and we still have quite a
few i think we'll have to we'll
we'll stick around for a little bit
while longer um
oh my god i think we've got a lot of
questions we've got a lot of questions
so
but i wanted to um i know i skimmed
through and i looked and i noticed that
there's been
quite a few questions relating to how
you
take the whole brain imaging data and
you know interpret and um register and
segment that i think maybe helpful if
you were to briefly comment a little bit
on the whole brain data
how you take that from raw data to
analysis
and what you know what that has done for
your
for your research program
everyone buckle up it's going to be
about another hour
okay let's try to keep it um
yeah so there
are so many amazing tools
in development or that have already been
released
that can aid people going from these
whole brain data sets
to a registration and ultimately
segmentation
what we're using currently uh is a
combination we use a multi-model
approach where we use clear map
um developed by chris christopher kurst
who just opened his lab at
uh university of uh san francisco like a
month and a half ago
i'm sure he'll be looking for post docs
and students shortly so if this type of
thing
interests you i would look them up we
use clear map
as our first base it's a fully automated
voxel-based system
which basically registers our samples to
the allen brain atlas common coordinate
framework but
that is a black box and so a lot of
times what we find during our clearing
and imaging process
is some of the brains get damaged or
they're not quite as uniformly
shaped as we would like for these
automated processes
so we've incorporated a second system
which we call
whole brain smart which there's a
preprint for
as well so basically there's a beautiful
r based package called
whole grain which uh
written by daniel firth uh which uh
allows
for spline-based manual semi-manual
registration of whole brain
images again to the same allen framework
but what you can go in is actually add
individual
annotation or correspondence points on
the interior of your images so that you
can find your
your histological landmarks even in a
damaged brain
and get it mapped on well enough and so
um
one of uh our students uh back at nida
uh wrote a great program called smart
which basically
makes it really straightforward um using
console based commands rather than
command lines
to take a large data set like a 4 000 6
000 8 000
image data set for a whole brain and put
it through the whole brain pipeline
and combined using these first fully
automated approaches
and then semi-manual approaches to make
corrections when things don't work
has been working really well and so
that's sort of our
our general approach now that said i
cannot speak highly enough of the
many programs that are currently trying
to push us even further towards full
automation
uh cell finder um developed by adam
tyson comes up
in mind most recently as an approach
that looks incredibly promising
for these types of analyses um there's
what else clear map 2 just got released
we're not as familiar with that so i
can't speak to that yet
uh miracle uh developed i believe in
collaboration with the deiseroth lab
out of stanford is another approach uh
which looks very promising and so
i mean there's no one of course is the
cubic is the cubic system as well which
uh has some beautiful things coming out
i think in the next month online
that are also going to allow these types
of approaches so there's a lot
there's no one simple answer for how do
you register
and and how do you
segment do you do it using machine
learning approaches do you use it just
using
setting basic thresholds for different
criteria for what a fast positive or
cell is
and i guess the take-home here
is people need to find the one that
works the best with their pipeline
i i would like to think there will be a
more unified approach moving forward
we're not there yet in my opinion
it's sort of a wild west to be honest
right now
and again the keys here in my mind are
the same ones that we tried to employ in
simba
which is explainability transparency
and the ability for humans to come in
and validate at key checkpoints
because a lot of stuff still does happen
as a black box it's great for usability
it's less great for having a lot of
faith in and how robust the data is that
we're getting out
and so i think whatever pipeline
ultimately does become the most
standardized pipeline we'll have a lot
of those checkpoints that allows
the the user to go in and actually see
how good the registration is make
and you know modification to the
registration as needed
see how good the segmentation is under
different parameters
across the whole brain uh and then
whoever creates this dream system will
be very popular let's put it that way
um i if you really really want the
details of how we do this i suggest you
check out the smart preprint
uh that's up on bio archive um
i think that's a probably the most
detailed starting point for people who
are interested
yeah the the landing page for this
webinar has some
links on the probably on the right side
of your screen i think
and one of those is for the golden lab
and if you go to the golden lab website
you can
check out the yeah the smart preprint
uh is linked there it's gone um
excellent thanks a lot sam so i mean
we've had a great talk here and
unfortunately i think we're running out
on out
low on time so we only will answer one i
think one more question
it sort of follows off from the comments
you just made about
um alignment and it i'm going to
summarize a few different questions but
um one is here from um ted ostin
i think you know know him at nida um
and um he says hello sam beautiful talk
and work how closely do regions that are
activated in various paradigms
match atlas defines cytoarchitectural
regions
i think this question is similar to
several others
yeah that is a fantastic question um
so in our most complete data set
which we feel we have all of the control
groups
and we have all we have a high enough
number of brains per group that we feel
really comfortable with the data we
haven't done an unsupervised
analysis yet but it's on the list of
things we absolutely want to do
right now i can tell you anecdotally we
see
very very clear areas of foss that
just map beautifully beautiful
beautifully under previously identified
subregion architecture we certainly also
see brain regions where there seems to
be
a much more of a continuum of false
activity
that you know spreads around the
classically defined regions
we we have to dig into that and we need
that we need to better understand that
right now i'm not really
i i can say we see it i don't know what
it means we certainly
haven't taken advantage yet i didn't
talk about it but
obviously there are some really
fantastic tools that allow us to
manipulate
behaviorally activated neural ensembles
in that case for example manipulating
the neurons that are active during the
behavior which certainly means not just
ones that are constrained
to a specific sub-region that we're
targeting and i think as we roll out
those experiments
we'll be better able to say you know
what's the causal what's the functional
role of these populations
that don't fall within these super
well-defined previously identified
uh regions of interest as identified by
the by the aba um we see them we don't
know what they mean yet
we don't know if they're if it's one
contiguous
different region or if it's just maybe
two adjacent regions that are both
you know now we think they are when
they're just both playing a role
these are all things we need to look
into now that we have these data sets
where we're not just looking at
very specific uh subnuclei
uh you know individually it's a great
question
and uh i wish i had a more concrete
answer other than say yeah we really
want to know
what's going on with that
can i answer some questions i see a
couple that i like
oh i'm fine with that i still have time
i think if if the lab routes uh
uh team will let us continue a little
bit longer then you can
certainly you can spot the ones you're
interested in answering among that list
um all right there's a lot of technical
questions here
which i'm not gonna answer but i think
should have a discussion
so i'm just going to say feel free to
email me uh
if we didn't cover your question and
yeah we might bet
to to this whole list so everyone's
everyone's list here we'll work together
and we'll
we'll get everybody a response yeah
yeah so i guess one um
that i'd really like to talk about that
i don't have an answer to
is sex differences in aggression um
you know that's a really complicated
answer because for example we've tried
in
uh cd ones and c50 since well both
outbread
and inbred mice female mice to get them
to lever press
for aggressive interactions and we've
been unable to
elicit aggressive aggressive behavior
under those conditions we can
certainly train female mice to lever
press for affiliative
self-administration with a peer uh where
they can then as
you know mice not as rats but as mice
interact they will go on and show those
types of social interactions
but we've not been able to do it with
aggression um
that said obviously female mice
show aggression under certain
ethologically relevant conditions
under the maternal conditions maternal
aggression is a fantastic example
the michigan lab recently emily newman
showed a procedure for eliciting robust
aggression
in female once as an example it still
requires some
some gestational components but it's
certainly a procedure that can be used
to answer this question
so that's something we're struggling
with and i would love to have a dialogue
with
the social behavior community on what is
the
most ethologically appropriate way to
incorporate
aggression research into sex as a
biological variable
because it's very hard to do since the
mice don't natively do it on their own
and if you're artificially inducing it
is that it certainly will identify
mechanisms but are those mechanisms one
we really want to go after if they're
artificial
things of that nature and so i think
that's going to be a real hot topic
that the whole field needs to really try
to address
moving forward one thing that we have
been doing in collaboration with emily
um is looking at the architecture of
aggression between male and female cd1s
are they similar are they different i
mean is aggression
the same behaviorally or can we really
reveal
differences using both supervised and
unsupervised approaches and i think
that's a good start
i think once we can get a hand on the
behavioral differences
in these models then we can start
getting a better idea of how to
to look at the neural the neural
similarities or differences
that we can find but it's a really
complicated discussion because
again in most of our models that's like
a royal us
it's very challenging to elicit
aggressive behavior in females
um and and when it is illicit is it it's
it's elicited under
very specific uh conditions to females
and so that's a really important
discussion that
we need to have and continue to have it
certainly has started
uh and and then figure out what the the
neural
you know the underlying neural
mechanisms are for these similarities
and differences
um can i pick another one
sure thanks man all right we appreciate
it
there's just a lot to pick from here so
i want to
see if we can
yeah we still have a lot of people
hanging on the call so i really
appreciate everyone's interest
um
yeah so this is another really good
general question which again i'm not
sure i have
an answer for but what are the
appropriate controls
for whole brain data sets um
you know when you're just looking at the
nucleus accumbens or you're just looking
at the central amygdala you
whether it's correct or not often aren't
viewing
motor activity as something that needs
to be controlled for us closely we
probably should be right
but it seems like oh that's not a motor
center so we don't really need to
maybe build in controls that take that
into account whereas when we're doing
something with whole grain brain
and we're getting everything in a
completely unbiased manner across
the motor cortex the visual cortex the
auditory cortex feeding into all of our
subcortical regions
those questions become really important
how do we what is our baseline
i don't have an answer for that i see
that that question has come up a lot i
think
what we need to do our design
experiments with the most appropriate
groups
for the behaviors that we're really
interested in so for example for a level
pressing behavior
where it's really hard for example to
disambiguate the role of context to an
operand chamber
from the lever press itself
you know right now i think from these
whole brain approaches we're still going
to get relatively messy data sets but
what we're going to be able to do with
these data sets
are start to go in and look at these
non-canonical regions that seem to be
activated
that we haven't had a reason to look at
before and as we inactivate those or
activate those using various approaches
we'll really be able to tie in a much
more complete systems level
understanding of what's occurring it's a
really hard question it's a really
good question what are the appropriate
controls and i think it's very dependent
upon the behavior and the designs that
have been
that have been uh selected for the
procedures that are being used with
these whole brain data sets
but yeah i mean you get everything you
can't hide anything if the whole cortex
is lit up
it's very obvious and then you need to
understand is that just because of
the queue is that because of this and
using foss that's not
available yet we don't have that
temporal resolution for locking in
to really discrete components of the
behavior and i'm only going to say
we're very aware of this caveat and
there are active pro projects going on
right now
where we hope to be able to much more
cleanly delineate
the window of behavioral activity much
much better than what's available with
current tools
but that's a story for probably another
year which hopefully we'll be able to
share
but we'll see how that goes
excellent well thank you again
dr golden for your time today and for
all this
important research i think we're seeing
you know how your work with
big behavior big imaging machine
learning
this is all coming together and really
taking advantage of
the latest innovations and developments
and technologies so it's very exciting
i'd like to thank labruz for hosting
this webinar
and on behalf of miltoni biotech
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for all these
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided the
registration so we'll be forwarding all
of that
those to sam and um as well um
so lab routes will alert you
via email when this webinar is available
for replay it
may take about 30 minutes or so to have
that process it should be probably
available later today
you'll be able to view it on demand if
you had any technical difficulties this
time
so until next time i think
that's all and then and sam and i will
sign out and
hope you all have a nice day and stay
safe out there
thank you